joining me here is a basketball hall of
famer one of the greatest michigan
wolverines of all time and he was in the
locker room in
the victorious locker room after
michigan made its fifth consecutive
sweet 16
on behalf of his good fab five friend
and head coach of the michigan
wolverines juwan howard the great chris
webber is here on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line how are you doing c webb
hey what's up rich and uh i'm so glad
you admitted you know how wrong you were
with that omission segment
a good man thank you to always uh make
sure he goes back and apologizes and so
make sure you let people know what's
going on right now yeah i did i i you
know i left out the fact yesterday when
i was crowing about the michigan
wolverine athletic situation and by
situation i mean
kicking ass and name-taking um uh that i
forgot to mention that the michigan
hockey team is number one ranked uh uh
currently in the michigan in the hockey
tournament so do you ever spend any time
in the in the great yoast ice arena
chris you ever do that back in the day
oh yeah oh yeah you know i i went to
yeah i went gang i went to games there
and i used to go to red wings games and
i used to love it it was like football
you know football on ice so uh yeah i
was definitely a big fan all michigan
athletics but i definitely got to a
couple games up there at yours do you
bang on the glass are you a glass banger
when you go to a hockey game chris i got
to i got to bang on the glass my friend
uh adrian to know when he took me to a
hockey game in high school and that was
the best moment but at yours no i
probably wasn't
stupid
[Laughter]
what was it like
uh to be just hugging it out with juwan
after that i saw you went right up to
him and you guys were hopping up and
down and hugging each other walk me
through that moment
from the other day chris
it was awesome so first shout out to the
michigan fans there and the family's
there
i was sitting there with people it was
so funny that i'd known over 30 years
that
were personal friends of jawan's
and so that was awesome and then you
know ray jackson really
is the impetus of uh coming back to all
the games and hanging out he's been uh
you know
uh just just getting me out all the time
and so he's been on me and so we were
gonna go back to a game before
and uh we didn't get a chance to and so
you know that moment hugging juwan ray
kind of moves out the way because he
wants us to have our home moment
and then he brings us in and uh you know
jawan and i communicate all the time we
talk we see each other i love his family
his wife is wonderful however i haven't
been there to support him and so
i was so nervous
that you know i just went over to hug
him and then like let's go you know and
then he's he starts jumping and hugging
and my knees hurting and so i'm just
trying to jump at myself but uh it's
just it was just a special moment man
that was just true
joy that's all i can say it was just
true joy um seeing the underdogs get the
win and being there to support and then
you went in the locker room i saw that
video that was fun
that was great
you know
what i'm serious what is it like for you
to be back in the michigan basketball
locker room like that chris
yeah you know it's something that um
man you know it's you know it it's it
was surreal uh but at the same time it
was
familiar you know what i mean i'm fans i
you know i've known juan son says he's
been in diapers uh the other players
there i've known some
you know seen them grow up and so to me
you know howard eisley uh the great
offensive coordinator there i played
against him in high school
and in india and so him being from
detroit so to me you know i grew up a
michigan and michigan state fan
obviously michigan is the better
school and situation obviously but you
know just growing up in the state of
michigan
you know it's like watching 89 when they
were winning you know
winning a championship and watching
ramil hit the free throws you know what
i mean so it was just so familiar to
feel good like i can't
i can't express i'm not trying to
downplay it in any way it it felt so
good but part of it feeling good was the
familiarity of it you know what i mean
it wasn't it wasn't the outsider or you
know anything else it was you know it
was it was just awesome to be there so
and and it was the kids time to shine
they won it happened the right way no
one stole their son and so it was just
the perfect situation and even seeing
you know uh chandler uh in the back
kennedy
um i'm such a fan of his and even just
as a competitor when i saw him in the
back and we're hugging um all i was
telling him is that i'm proud of him and
that i'm glad he's trying because it
means that he wanted to win like you
deserve to cry everyone doesn't deserve
to cry they can laugh they can say this
that's cause they're quitters and
they're scared of failure so who cares
about haters who are scared to fail you
know the man in the arena quote kind of
and telling him to embrace it because
only
only guys that really wanted are the
ones that do it and i'm proud of you
because i know when you go to the nba
these emotions will still be in you
whether it's this year the next year and
so just proud of all the kids effort the
big fella from you know michigan our
guards our guard play guys that were on
the bench that waited to come in the
right time and you know being able to
really let them know like
who cares about what's going on social
media this area you guys are
are great because you came together as a
team so it was just really good being
able to reinforce you know those
positive positive messages because as an
athlete you know that's all it's about
chris webber here on the rich eisen show
and we're seeing the video of juwan
jumping up and down with the players and
water being thrown in the air and it's
just a a joyous locker room and
you know
i got to just bring it up too the the
shot of that that went viral as well it
should of of juwan of coach howard um
hugging a member of tennessee's team
that was crying on the line on the
handshake line and hugging this kid
in contrast to what happened on the
handshake line
at wisconsin
is stark to say the least it is
remarkable and now
um coach howard is going to the sweet 16
this young man is not going there
i'm wondering what what your thought was
when juwan was going through his
suspension and you saw what had happened
on the line in wisconsin in the
conversation that was a national
conversation about
juwan howard chris webber
yeah and i i'll get to that and and that
young man his name is kennedy chandler
and juan recruited him
and wanted him bad at the university of
michigan and he has a wonderful mother
and father and we were talking him in
the back and so that's who juan is
who else can hug you except for god has
had
i think one thing about empathy
um
empathy has definitely an understanding
for it and the sensitivity but true
empathy holds you accountable because
you've been there before and you can say
hey i know you've been there but you
still can't do that so
uh when i watched the game i couldn't
believe it um
you know what what what transpired in
that game in the line
i communicated with juwan weeks before
the weeks after the day of you know all
that good stuff
uh from
the second that it was and the second
being with me maybe an hour after the
game
uh you know he communicated you know
you know how sorry he was and if anyone
knows juwan he's a man of conviction
but just as happy as he was uh you know
joining the team i'm emotionally happy
you know he was just as distraught you
know on the other end and more so for
the representation of you know his
family he knew he could get a
coaching job i think it was reported
that nine nba teams called him right
away uh that next day and he didn't care
about any of that he cared about uh the
young men in the locker room so that's
that's who he is and so
while that you know
surprised me and there's no excuse for
it and
uh it didn't surprise me you know how
caring he was and the fact that you know
you really got to think about it for the
young man to
go over there and to speak to juwan and
speak myself after means means something
from juwan's perspective um
you know because you know yeah juwan's
gonna console a kid right how many times
is a kid from another team
uh no disrespect to his coach
but heads the other way
to the other coach that just beat him
and just says you know and just falls in
your arms so says a lot about who he is
and uh a long time before this incident
ever happened and again
um he's taken any better take and he has
taken and he needs to move forward but
he's taken full responsibility for it
and
you know thank god he gets an
opportunity through these moments in our
plan to show who he really is well you
know the x's and o's too what makes
jawan howard a good coach
chris
oh man um i i think um
iq i think having been in the game so
long played so long the great mentoring
of coaches that he has you know
everybody talks about the pop of his
tree which you should but he's under the
rally tree and so um i think one of the
things is that he's made adjustments uh
he's been in the game in the transition
i think like yourself or any of these
other uh you know great uh guys in the
media i think not that the younger
generation doesn't have an advantage by
being familiar
but i think there's an advantage to
context and being an advantage to
transition so you know i'm not trying to
date you but i'm sure you were you were
on tv with bait with with uh vcrs
yeah they might have set the vcr for a
sports center back in the day chris yeah
you know i used to be in the studio with
dats and things like that but i think
that when you see new technology new um
situation that it just makes you you
know it just gives you a better context
and i think that his empathy his context
um he's the age of their parents he has
the kid in school uh you know he knows
what you're going through and i think
that sensitivity really holds him
accountable again you know he's he's you
know since i met you know all the guys
and some of the best men that i know so
i'm definitely not surprised with uh who
he is um as a family man first and then
as a coach
chris webber basketball hall of famer
here on the rich eisen show for a few
more minutes okay let me just talk a
little nba with you if you don't mind uh
last night lebron dropped a
triple-double on cleveland and it was uh
quite a moment for him as well you know
when he soaked in the uh thunderous
applause uh when uh they put up on the
on the scoreboard that he passed
carmalone for second uh most points in
the history of the nba he said he's
having the time of his life
do you
believe him when you hear that for a
team that's mired in ninth
right now in the west
chris you know what i um
yes and i think that he has to have the
time of his life because he know that he
knows that time is fleeting so i think
one i think the most underrated story in
sports is that he passed carl malone
number two
i mean i can't imagine in baseball that
someone was you know past number two and
was on you know a couple years away or
whatever so i'm not to be having triple
doubles at this age to go back to his
hometown and do it i mean
and yes in a true argument i would say
well you know it hasn't been broken
because other guys couldn't come until
they were 22 and they played more games
we can say all of that but what he has
just done is the most incredible thing
that we've ever seen and so he's made up
clubs as far as uh the 40-10-10 club or
whatever clubs that he's had so
hopefully he is enjoying it because i
tell you what he hates losing so it's
either going crazy hate losing or trying
to find but trying to find that balance
you know in the rainbow so he needs to
embrace being able to chase some
personal goals but i know it's killing
them that um
you know they better play well because
they they may not even make the the play
in so uh hopefully he is enjoying it
while working his ass off to try to make
it to the playoffs yeah there's ten
games to go um and the aforementioned
greg popovich
is the is the team that can you know
maybe get in there's a tent see they're
too behind the pelicans and three behind
the lakers who are currently ninth um i
i i guess it's an open-ended question do
you think the i mean the lakers have won
two of three they're talking about maybe
going on a special run who the heck
knows but
it doesn't look good at all right i mean
like what do you what do you think about
the lakers chances chris yeah i think
there's teams we can root for as fans
but i think the great thing about all
the leagues is are that it's so
competitive so
you know i i don't know i don't think i
think it's going to be tough you know
like lebron had to have a triple double
they'd be winning all this incredible
things that they've had to do to
maintain it and it just seems as if
it would be hard to maintain this even
though they're trying to move up so you
know i i would say just as a the guy
loves basketball it doesn't look great
for them but with lebron and what he's
been doing
they always have a chance but but even
in the play on series and i know people
like anything can happen that way it's
just really hard to fight without this
consistency whether you them or a great
team like golden state i just think
there's just you know so much
accountability with
uh officiating now i think there's so
much parody um i think the fans are so
smart that you're not gonna slip
anything over them and so being that all
those eyes are in anyone has a chance
and you know i i think that's all
they're saying is just let us get to the
afc and we can do anything and hopefully
they do because it will make a great
playoff series who is who's your team in
the east what do you think
chris i'm sorry who's the team in the
east if you had to choose one
my favorite team team is most fun to
watch it has to be you know um
to me it has to be brooklyn you know i i
really like what houston i mean with um
houston with hardin right and the sixers
have there but i just don't think they
have enough scoring you know the reason
why i really like brooklyn
is because everyone undervalues the seth
curry trade or the fact that this team
got shooters this team has shooters now
so at the end of the day remember what
we said a few years ago about philly
they don't have shooters well they still
don't have shoes and they still don't
have a bench and yes embiid is playing
great ball and harden playing great ball
but the reason why it's hard for them to
close is because they don't have those
closures at the end and if deandre
drummond if he just plays his role he
doesn't try to post up or go one-on-one
none of that just rebound tip the ball
in and play defense then i think you
know brooklyn has a chance but anthony
cooper and those guys have something to
say but i think brooklyn definitely is
going to be the most fun to watch all
right chris before i let you go uh you
always like jumping in at the end of our
conversations to talk about this subject
so i'll just set you up uh on on who the
um
the super bowl winning quarterback was
this past year
so first of all i'd like to shout out a
friend if i could and some partners that
coin lectables and my
toby o'connor we have some special
things this week and i was telling my
friends
got some special things to announce
hopefully you know you'll let me back on
and we're doing some wonderful things in
the nft the metaverse and signing and
experiences with all type of athletes
and but as i was telling them the other
day football i can't say is my favorite
sport but because that would be kind of
blasphemous but it is tied for my
favorite sport and i remember coming on
a friend of mine's show last year
and telling them that you know i bet
that my quarterback and my t.o voice i
think i even text him a couple times
probably getting on his nerves during
the year saying remember what i told you
and
matthew stafford
all the people that called and hated on
my twitter account and instagram because
i said matthew stafford was gonna win
and
uh aaron donald was the best and koopa
cub
everybody that you know i just want to
say
i told you so
i love that
i love it
i love it because i'm i'm looking right
now um
at uh my phone um i believe this was
after the nfc championship game okay um
a certain friend um you know who may
have been a member of the fab five
uh texted me that's my with uh all caps
m.y
quarterback
and there there's nine exclamation
points at the end of it and underneath
it underneath it it says sent with siri
so i don't know how do you get nine
exclamation points when you send
something with siri chris webber how do
you do that siri me and siri have a
special relationship and i was screaming
i was screaming in the phone so siri
knew what time it was i told her early
too that when the trade happened don't
worry siri we're allowing him to go
there so he can win the championship you
know but i knew it was good i didn't get
one after the super bowl that's kind of
weird i'll be honest with you chris i
was expecting it i got it a handful of
times and then after the the ultimate
i didn't get one but that i was hoping
you were okay but that's pretty cool oh
yeah i probably you know did you see
aaron donald on the on the bus when he
was uh you know he took off his shirt
and all that stuff that's what i was
doing with my gut here at home so that's
all i was just celebrating man i was
just celebrating i know and it looks
like the rams might be set up to try and
do it again you know what i'm saying but
it's nice
they do you got to let me back on and
make make another prediction i think i
earned that with you know a football
savant like yourself if i get lucky one
year at least gotta let me come back on
and see if i can get lucky but i gotta
you know i gotta look through uh you
know some scouting reports and consult
with a couple gyms and then i'll i'll
get back to you and let you know my
picks are for this upcoming season okay
very good nine exclamation points
stafford where's the number nine that i
think that's non-exclamation point yeah
one for everyone
okay there you go she's a staffer fan as
well okay
serious
well chris it's always a pleasure to
talk to you and i'll just be honest with
you seeing you next to ray jackson and
hugging out uh with uh juwan howard at a
michigan uh
um
ncaa tournament win and then you in the
locker room and you seeing you with the
block m on your on your
chest you know wearing the gear is
pretty cool man speaking on behalf of
all wolverines glad to see
and on behalf of myself i just thank all
the wolverines that were patient and uh
the one thing that you know again juan
and i've never had any trouble we've
always been there but hopefully this is
the start for you know the enjoyment of
all fibers to be back which i think it
will and uh it was really cool last
thing before i get off i came home and
my son
had on my uh old college varsity jacket
my wife ported out the uh
you know what i'm going to post that
right now since i came on your show but
my wife posted like my wife had a
picture of and i came home and i saw him
that was pretty cool so many more
moments to share but it was special my
friend and thank you over the years for
uh you know always uh pushing me forward
for that of course absolutely all five
of you huh because hey look man if if
ray allen and uh and kg are hugging it
out let's go chris yeah
if there's water under that bridge
there's no other bridge that came water
can't be under you know what i'm saying
no doubt man all love okay take care of
yourself chris weber we'll look for that
picture be well thanks again always a
pleasure thanks again right back at you
chris weber everybody right here on the
right
all five
you heard that right yeah
it has to happen the ground will shake
when that happens
in the michigan wolverine and i think
just
ncaa
basketball world yeah writ large hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here